[音楽]
今日は外れ社長です
天気が悪いねなんか最近天気が悪くて3パットせないんですけども
マイ冊
味噌汁とかさ革命を作るときどうやって作ってるん
水道水かあ水道水を沸かして使うだねなるほどなるほど
パーンとだよ
バーズリーがわからないいつでもさそういう星一つになると思うんじゃねぇ
緊急時のような水ヶ岳なることだってあるんだよやら今日は何もないたちにな星こと
なんか水道とか先ほど全然水道さを普段気軽に使える脚んした水がないときの対処これ
が郷愁と思う
集計表ですねあーんあーねっ今から
雨水でみそ汁をつくって述べるかどうかを確かめてみようと思います前田ちゃん枚すぎ
なんだよいつでもな
安心で安全で飲める店があると思うよねーぞ
きれいな水っていうのだ作るのに行くとっても大変なんだ
多分本来あるべき味ではそれが自然なじゃあ張っても楽しまないとダメだと思うんだよ
というわけで姉とってくれ
結構よ実はな
そう強いんだよだけでいい
あのバケットあるいるばキッズじゃねーよフライパン用意したんでそれだけこういう
感じで集めます
タイプ
俺死なねーかなー
[音楽]
エレノアの水が収束する
してるあまりそう
言い何カールですね
背中車
[拍手]
結構とありましたいや案内ねーいけそうですよ
ちょっと透明なポップで組んでみましょう
[音楽]
肉眼で確認できますでしょうか何かが渦巻いておりますああこれはわかりやすい
なんかねえちょいっと浮いてるんですよ
ルールはマジかマジか乗って汚いまぢかー
焼けば棒を振ってきたので僕も作れますよ相次ぎないあの道でみそ汁を作ってんだろう
と思います
これは知らないよねやだわー
批判になってきたわー雨水セット編み図異常な
青水転換雨水範囲コーン注意花別に場が4
冬部発見
穴水異常なしこれこれをもったというかさ結構沸騰でさ殺菌できると思うんだよね意外
とイケるんじゃねーなーこれないような女が出来てるぞ
様よりキタキタキター違うところを言ってね何かおかしいよね何か違うとか覚えてるよ
ね
入っかやばいやばいなんかおかしいどっちかというとあれだドライバーの下から出てる
んじゃぱ
目でもわかるで何か浮い
いるのはこれは何なんだろうねこれが出てるって事はもう完璧に多分
風に熱しされてますね相次ぎお味噌汁を作ります地味でシジミを作ろう
チヂミ入りましたあれだおい編ねこれこぼしたらしいねこれコースからそりゃ3着生
いやーこれをこぼすたら死ぬねー
あぁはぁなんか上がるわーおい破る安打を言わざる
和書してきましたが出来ましたそれぞこれをちょっとこれが硬ければ
アモル誰だアフな奴だそれぞれだ入ってるなんとかできましたーっと実はね意外と普通
のビザ知る
普通普通22位とって2なぜも見た目じゃないのは百も承知なんでね
なんか全くちゃいましょう
変な病気今日のならない
いただきます
えっ
何だろうイベント行けるんだよね意外といけますこれ
意外といけるんじゃ本当に告ったらもうまずくて
うんな水っていうね綺麗なお家予想としてなんですけどそうではなかったんで
落ちは特にないです
あのローソンのミルフィーおいしいのでぜひ食べてみてください
[音楽]
ん
def